-I love -- I love --
I love having you here.
-Thank you.
I'm gonna try and sit --
I have such short legs,
always, on these shows.
I'm always like this.
-Well, you have them always,
not just on the show.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I know,
but the chairs are so damn deep.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-I'm gonna talk to you
about whatever
you think is best,
chair-wise, for next time.
We're gonna have a special --
-Thank you.
Gosh, Seth. Bring your "A" game.
-I love, by the way, that you're
going right at Blake Shelton.
This is what I hoped
with you as a coach.
Are you enjoying the transition
to being a coach on "The Voice"?
-Yes.
And, honestly, I love --
That's what makes this season
especially fun, I think,
even for the crew.
Like, Adam and Blake and I
all know each other.
Like, and they know
Alicia really well,
'cause they've done
a couple seasons with her.
So it makes it really fun,
'cause the banter --
We'll go in on each other, and
no one's like, "You're so mean."
Like, no one care--
You know, we're just, like --
We're messing around, you know?
But I do go in on Blake a lot.
-Yeah.
-But he's kind of
a giant target.
-Yeah. He's a giant man.
Like, when he
comes on this show,
his feet go through the floor.
-Yeah. Every time we do
a photo together for, like,
any promo you see, like,
I'm always on like two steps,
like, or otherwise,
I look like an Oompa Loompa.
Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause I'm like 5'3", so...
-Do you like
selling yourself as a coach
or is that a hard part
of the show for you?
-I love it. I'm so competitive.
Like, yeah, I'm kind of
annoyingly competitive.
I think a lot of
my friends are like,
"Oh, you were
so fun last night."
I'm like, "Well, wait, 'cause
there's a lot of personality
coming at you."
But I'm so excited about it
and I'm competitive.
So I do enjoy it.
But it sucks
when they don't pick you.
-Yeah.
-You feel defeated.
-Do you?
-You feel like you're crap,
and they're like,
"I'm not gonna be on your team."
-You've had all this success.
Even when a contestant on
"The Voice" doesn't choose you,
you take it personally.
-Oh, my God.
That's like all of us.
Like, we have a million people
who will be like,
"You're awesome,"
and, like, the one turd,
you're like,
"Why don't
they think I'm great?
What did I do wrong?"
You know, it's like, "What?"
-And then you say to the million
people who like you like,
"Why are you so stupid?!"
-Why did you lie to me?!
-You liars!
-It was not great.
-I actually know you
to be competitive,
because we did something --
Last time we hung out,
we did something called "Day
Drinking with Seth and Kelly."
And you told me you
were not a big drinker.
-I'm not.
-And we drank a lot.
-Yes.
-And you matched me
drink or drink.
-I did, but here's the thing.
You tricked me,
'cause I thought, like,
it was gonna be one of
those TV things,
where, like,
really don't drink a lot.
And, like, I was so happy
when it came out,
'cause, like,
there's a solid five minutes
where I didn't talk --
all I did was laugh --
that they had to edit out.
Like, I was so drunk.
-Yeah.
-Like, it was so sad.
Like, I am a lightweight.
-I was so drunk
that you were getting ready
for the last thing --
'Cause we went on the roof
of the hotel
to scream things out.
And I fell asleep
on the roof of the hotel.
But we actually have a clip.
This is us after
probably about 10 drinks each
in only 2 hours.
-That's amazing.
-Look, the important thing is
that we are on the roof
and we have each written things
for the other person
to yell from the roof,
because we've been
drinking all afternoon.
All right,
I'm gonna yell one first.
-Okay, you pick one.
-I tried breast-feeding,
and it kind of worked!
-I love the movie
"From Justin to Kelly"!
-Oh, I love it, too.
-It's good.
-It's so good.
-My moves are good.
-It's very underrated.
-My dance moves.
It's underrated.
Oh, my God. We're so drunk.
-We're both drunk.
You...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love that it's one --
Like, when you're drunk,
everything is one word.
Like, it's like...
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
It's like, "What?"
-I don't know if you
noticed this, but I --
When I was leaving,
I said, "Oh, God.
I haven't said goodbye to Kelly.
And I went over
and said goodbye,
and everybody told me later that
I had just said goodbye to you.
[ Laughter ]
-That's okay,
'cause you know what's funny?
I didn't know that.
-Oh, okay. Good.
-I was legit hammered.
-And you had to go to a --
-To my children.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-You went to your children?
-I did.
Luckily, my husband was there
and a qualified nanny
that takes care of children.
Don't take my children away.
No, I -- Literally, though,
it's kind of awesome,
'cause I've never been
day drinking.
Literally, that was my
one and only time.
And it's awesome,
because you don't get hung over,
'cause you sober up by 6:30.
-Yeah.
-And then you're like, "Well,
let's do this.
-Yeah.
-"I got this."
-And, speaking of your kids,
aren't your kids now --
'Cause I know you bring them on
the road with you all the time.
-I bring them here.
They're here.
-They're here.
And that's really great.
You spend a lot of
time with them.
Obviously, you wouldn't
see them that much
'cause you're on
the road so much.
-No. We work far too much, yeah.
-Are they excited now?
Do they know your songs?
-Oh, yes.
But my daughter's hilarious,
'cause she has no time
for Kelly Clarkson singing.
It's like we'll start singing,
and she'll be like, "Shh."
She'll go right up to my mouth.
"Shh. River's singing."
And I'm like, "Oh, my bad."
I'm like, "People pay for this,
but whatever."
Like, she shushes me.
Yeah. My son still likes it,
but, actually, he'll go,
"Aaah!"
Like, when you start singing,
if he doesn't like the song,
he'll go, "Aaah!"
Like, I should
test my albums on him.
-Yeah. Very traumatic.
It seems like your life with
your children is very traumatic.
-Well, not everyone sounds like
Julie Andrews in a field, y'all.
So, it's like I try.